Sega welcome to saru
games with Sonic Boom we have this
unique opportunity to work with isuka
son and Sonic team and to collaborate
with them on the development of the
characters and so we're able to expand
on that for our sonic boom and just you
know evolve the characters a bit more
for this new franchise that we're trying
to build up we're not taking it very
lightly that we are one of the few
Western developers that is able to get
our hands on the Sonic franchise and so
I'm really looking forward to the whole
gaming world to get a chance to see the
Western take on what Sonic is it was a
great opportunity to get a chance to
work uh with with Sonic we definitely
pulled from the past cuz we wanted Sonic
to look like Sonic and feel like Sonic
and move like Sonic but then we also
wanted to kind of adapt to this new
world it has the things that resonate
and make Sonic and that's something we
spend a lot of time on you know we look
at the old games we really pick them
apart and we make sure that those
elements are are in the new game as well
but with the new gameplay Styles we have
four playable characters each with their
own unique moves you could switch
between them at any time which is
totally new to to a Sonic game we want
to add New Dimensions that would make it
fun we've introduced the new villain
lyric um which is shared with the Wii U
version of the game now that in of
itself is giving us the Stepping Stones
to build on something bigger and
brighter for the future for Sonic
franchise top of that we want to
encourage exploration and so by
switching to a different character you
might be able to explore a new pocket of
gam play that otherwise wouldn't be
reached one of the cool gameplay
elements in in the game that's my
personal favorite is the beam and uh I
really like swinging from side to side
like Tarzan uh there's nothing seen
before like that in Sonic titles it is
this really cool electric thing that
comes from everybody's wrists and we use
it to Grapple onto this tether point and
swing across Giant chasms and enemies
are shielded with this entner beam
technology and so you have the power to
use your enter beam to rip off their
Shields before you can tackle them and
and take them on with four playable
characters play has tons of choices for
how they want to explore the adventure
levels with Sonic's air Dash he can Dash
Through Dash blocks he could reach um
Higher Grounds that Knuckles might not
be able to get to but at the same time
Knuckles offers his unique burrowing
abilities and so he might be able to
burrow through the walls and come up on
the other side of the wall where
otherwise a door or entryway might not
be accessible Tails has this ability to
hover and so we created these giant fans
that only he can jump into and then get
boosted out into the air so he's the one
that's able to reach the highest Heights
of all the levels using these fans and
for sticks it's her Boomerang the cool
thing with the boomerang is you get to
control it you can control it anywhere
you can get secret collectibles with it
you can unlock little puzzles and um
it's really a fun mechanic uh you know
for the whole game and and definitely
brings out sticks personality sonic boom
shadow Crystal has a new playable
character sticks which is exclusive to
the 3DS and so this is really exciting
for us because we have have a lot of
freedom to develop this character and
make her fun and unique to just a 3DS
experience we knew that sticks need to
be playable character because she has a
boomerang and she's a female and I think
having strong female leads in games are
also very important we do have a
connectivity between the 3DS and the Wii
U depending on your progress in the 3DS
version that will unlock secrets and
allow you to play additional content on
the Wii U side if you're a Sonic fan
you're not only going to get one game to
pick from you have two totally different
games you want a big roaming 3D
Adventure game you know you have the Wii
U version which is awesome and then on
the 3DS version you know we have a lot
more uh 2D
2.5d uh classic gameplay with the four
characters that you can switch between
uh and you have sticks you know so I I
would say it's it's great to be a Sonic
fan you know when these games come out
cu you have two totally different games
to pick
from
all right thanks for coming and that is
a wrap